it's most likely the oldest alcoholic
drink in the world and you've probably
never even tasted it fermented honey
known as me is enjoying a Renaissance in
the US and london-based Mead maker goals
a newcomer on the scene is hoping for a
slice of the
action we've already maxed out our
production here so we're doing about 3
to 3 and a half thousand bottles a month
it's grown sort of 2,000% in a year um
in terms of volume going out of me in
the states which is pretty exciting so I
think there's definitely room for some
of that over here popularity in home
brewing and a Resurgence in craft beers
is helping create lots of interest but
the price of honey and falling bee
populations could be a fly in the
ointment for commercial success honey
generally is quite expensive it's
definitely more expensive than say malt
for beer or apples for cider this year
actually has been incredibly good for
bees uh so certainly there's been bump
of crops in London for for honey which
is good news brewed in a similar way to
cider Tom just adds honey yeast and
water then
Waits word of mouth has spread to a
number of high-end Outlets across the UK
like the swan which is located by
London's temps River next to
Shakespeare's Globe Theater where it was
probably enjoyed by The Bard
himself we literally just sort of
scoured the area and we thought let's
let's me what is me let's find out about
it we knew it was close by peckam so we
we got it in and you know the staff
management the team we like this is
great no one's got it let's get involved
let's try it Tom's me is even versatile
enough to be used as an ingredient for
delicious desserts it's a dessert you
want it sweet so it's it's got sweetness
on its own the the meat but putting all
together with a littleit sugar a little
bit gelatine a bit berries and all the
ice cream going in Foods kind of bring
it all together gives one another
dimension to it another flavor for now
at least it seems there's plenty of Fizz
about meat to be enjoyed for a few
centuries more
Tom Gibson
Bloomberg